we now have the general tools to really
tackle any multiplication problems so in
this video I'm just going to do a ton of
examples so let's start off with and
I'll start in yellow let's start off
with 32 times 18 32 times 18 say 8 times
2 is 16 I'll still let me just well I'll
do it in our head this time because you
always don't have all the space to work
with so 8 times 2 8 times 2 is 16 put
the one up there 8 times 3 is 24 24 plus
1 is 25 25 so 8 times 32 was 256 now
we're going to multiply this one which
is really a 10 times 32 underline it
with the orange one times 2 and we have
to be very careful here 1 times 2 is 2
so you might say hey let's me take a 2
down there but remember this isn't 2 1
this is a 10 so we have to stick a 0
there to remember that so 1 10 times 2
is 20 right or you could say 1 times 2
is 2 but you're putting it in the twos
place so you still get 20 so 10 times 2
is 20 works out then 1 times 3 and we
have to be very careful let's get rid of
what we had from before 1 times 3 is 3
there's nothing to add here so you just
get a 3 and so you get 10 times 32 is
320 right this one right here that's a
10 10 plus 8 is 18 so now we just add up
the two numbers you add them up 6 plus 0
is 6 5 plus 2 is 7 2 plus 3 is 5 let's
keep going let's hit do 99 times 88 it's
going to give us a big number 8 times 9
is 72 72 is to the 7 up there 8 times 9
and then you have 8 times 9 again 8
times 9 is 72 and I have the 7 up here
so 72 plus 7 is
79 79 fair enough now we are done with
this let's just delete it just so that
we don't get confused in our next step
and our next step we're going to
multiply this 8 now times 99 but this 8
is an 80 so let's take a 0 down there
8 times 9 is 72 stick a 7 up there then
8 times 9 is 72 plus 7 is 79 79 2 plus 0
is 2 let me switch colors 9 plus 2 is 11
carry the 1 1 plus 7 is 8 8 plus 9 is 17
hairs 1 1 plus 7 is 8 8712 let's keep
going can't do enough of these all right
53 times 78 I think you're getting the
hang of it now let's multiply 8 times 53
first so 8 times 3 is 24
stick the 2 up there 8 times 5 is 40 40
plus 2 is 42 42 now we're going to deal
with it seven that's seven right there
which is really a 70 so let's go
remember to put the zero there seven
times three and let's get rid of this
don't want to get confused 7 times 3 is
21 put the 1 there and put the 2 up here
7 times 5 is 35 plus 2 is 37 37 now
we're ready to add ready to add 4 plus 0
is 4 2 plus 1 is 3 4 plus 7 is 11 carry
the 1 1 plus 3 is 4 4134 let's up the
stakes a little bit let's up the stakes
so let's say I had 796 times
times fifty Oh
fifty-eight times 58 let's mix it up
well
alright let's so first we're going to
just multiply eight times seven hundred
ninety-six and notice I've thrown an
extra digit up here so 8 times 6 is 48
put the 4 up there 8 times 9 is 72 plus
4 is 76 76 and then 8 times 7 is 56 56
plus 7 is 63 63 I'm sure I'll make a
careless mistake at some point in this
video and the goal for you is to
identify if and when I do all right now
we're ready so we can get rid of these
guys up here now we can multiply this 5
which is in the tens place it's really a
50 times this up here because it's a 50
we stick a zero down there 5 times 6 is
30 put the zero there put the 3 up there
5 times 9 is 45 plus the 3 is 48 48 5
times 7 is 35 plus 4 is 39 39 now we're
ready to add I'm ready to add 8 plus 0
is 8 6 plus 0 is 6 3 + 8 3 plus 8 is 11
1 plus 6 is 7 7 plus 9 is 16 and then
one plus three is four so 796 times 58
is 46,000 168 and that sounds up about
right because 796 it's almost 800 it's
all you know which is almost 1,000 so
it's you know if we multiplied a
thousand times 58 we'd get 58 thousand
but we're multiplying something a little
bit smaller than a thousand times 58 so
we're getting something a little bit
smaller than 58,000 so the number is in
though in the correct ballpark now let's
just do one more here where I'm really
going to step up the stakes
let's do five hundred and twenty three
times I'm going to do a three-digit
number now times 798 that's a big
three-digit number but it's the same
exact process and you should once you
kind of see the pattern you say hey this
will apply to any time number of digits
times any a number of digits it'll just
start taking a long time and your
chances of making a careless mistake are
going to go up but it's the same idea so
we start with eight times 523 8 times 3
is 24
stick the 2 up there let me now 8 times
2 is 16 16 plus 2 is 18 the one up there
8 times 5 is 40 plus one is 41 so eight
times fifth 523 is 4184 we're not done
we have to multiply it times the 90 and
divide with a 700 so let's do the 90
right there so it's a 90 so we'll just
stick a zero there it's not a 9 so 9
time and let's get rid of these guys
right there 9 times 3 is 27 9 times 3 is
27 9 times 2 is 18
18 plus 2 is 20 and then we have 9 times
5 is 45 45 plus 2 is 47 40 I don't want
to write that thick 47 let me make sure
I did that one right and let's just
review it a little bit 9 times 3 it was
27 we wrote the 7 down here and put the
2 up there
9 times 2 is 18 we added 2 to that so we
wrote 20 wrote the 0 down there and the
2 up there the 9 times 5 was 45 plus 2
is 47 you really have to make sure you
don't make careless mistakes with these
then finally we have to multiply the 7
which is really a 700 times 523 and for
a 91 was just an 8 we just started
multiplying
when it was a 90 when we were doing with
a tens place we put a zero there now
that we're doing something that's in the
hundreds we're going to put two zeroes
there two zeroes right there and so you
have seven and let's get rid of this
stuff that'll just mess us up seven
times three seven times three is
twenty-one
put the one there stick the two up there
7 times 2 is 14 14 plus r2 is 16 16 put
the one up there 7 times 5 is 35 plus
one is 36 36 and now we're ready to add
and hopefully we didn't make any
careless mistakes so four plus zero plus
zero that's easy that's 4 8 plus 7 plus
zero that's 15 carry the 1 one plus one
plus one is three four plus seven plus
six that's what's four plus six is ten
17 17 and then we have one plus four is
five 5 plus 6 is 11 carry the 1 one plus
three is four so 523 times 798 is four
hundred seventeen thousand three hundred
and fifty four and we can even check to
make sure and so this is the moment of
truth let's see if if we add let's see
523 times seven hundred ninety-eight
there you go moment of truth I don't
have to re-record this video it's four
hundred seventeen thousand three hundred
fifty four but we did it without the
calculator which is the important point